هذا ويفرض الجيش الاسرائيلي طوقا امليا
مشددا على منطقه اريحا بعد مقتل مستوطن في
اطلاق نار في منطقه الاغوار جنوب البحر
الميت ونشرت قواته الاحتلال حواجز عسكريه
وعززت قواتها عززت قواتها في محيط المدينه
بحثا عن منفذيه هجوم يوم امس الاثنين الذي
اسفر عن مقتل مستوطن اسرائيلي
من اريحا مراسل جزيره سمير ابو شمالي ينضم
الينا
واضحه خلفك الصوره ولعلها جزء من هذا
التطبيق المستمر لريحه سمير
نعم بكل تاكيد ربما يكون هذا المشهد هو
مغاير لما راينا قبل ساعه او قبل المداخله
الماضيه نحن الان نتواجد عند المدخل
الجنوبي لمدينه اريحا هناك طابور من
السيارات الخاصه بالمواطنين الفلسطينيين
ينتظرون لساعات طويله
لاجتياز هذا الحاجز خاصه للخارجين من
مدينه اريحا تقوم قوات الاحتلال وجنود
الاحتلال بتدقيق في الهويات الشخصيه وايضا
بالتفتيش المركبات نحن على مدار الساعه
الاخيره ايضا
تحدثت الى كثير من المواطنين الذين
اجتازوا هذا المكان قالوا بان هناك انتظار
لساعات طويله انتظروا في هذا المكان ولكن
كل هذه الاجراءات هي تعطل جميع مستويات
حياتهم اليوميه المعيشيه الحياتيه وحتى
على مستوى التجاريه وايضا السياحيه في هذا
المكان وفي هذه المدينه التي
تشتهر بالسياحه في هذا الموسم بالتحديد
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو يشدد من اجراءاته
للخارجين ويخفف من الداخلين ولكن الداخلين
يعرفون بانهم اذا خرجوا سينتظرون ساعات
طويله للخروج مره اخرى من مدينه اريحا هذه
الاجراءات العسكريه على جميع مداخل ومخارج
مدينه اريحة جاءت في اجراءات عقابيه
لمدينه اريحا بعد او في اطار البحث
والتفتيش وتنشيط على منفذي هجوم يوم امس
الذي ادى الى مقتل
مستوطن اسرائيل يبلغ من العمر 25 عاما
وايضا هو يحمل الجنسيه الامريكيه قد تم
اطلاق النار عليه من مجموعه من المسلحين
حسب بيان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيليه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي تتزامن مع اجراءات اخرى
اضافيه موجوده في مدينه نابلس وتحديدا في
القرى والبلدات المتواجده والواقعه جنوب
مدينه نابلس حيث هناك ايعاز الوزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليه
بتعزيز والدفع بكتيبه رابعه اضافيه من
جنود الاحتلال وقوات من الشباك وشرطه حرس
الحدود الى الطرقات وايضا لتامين وحمايه
المستوطنين خلال تنقلهم وتواجدهم على
الطرق الرئيسيه والعامه وايضا في محيط
المستوطنات على المستوى السياسي ايضا
نحن نتحدث عن ان امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه
لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين الشيخ قد
طالب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون
الفلسطينيه هذه عامر خلال اللقاء جمعهما
اليوم في رام الله طلبه بتوفير الحمايه
للفلسطينيين اذا هذه الجرائم وهذه
الاعتداءات من قبل جيش الاحتلال وايضا
المستوطنين التي شهدتها الاراضي
الفلسطينيه في اليومين الاخيرين بالتحديد
جمله هذه المستوطنه هذه الاعتداءات من
الوسطين كانت مرعبه من المشاهد التي ايضا
كان لهذه عمر جوله تفاقديه وقد اطلع اكثر
عن قرب بين المواطنين واستمع للشهادات
المواطنين حول الاحداث والمشاهد المروعه
التي شاهدوها خلال اليومين الماضيين وايضا
الاعتداءات التي كانت على الفلسطينيين مما
ادى الى استشهاد فلسطين وايضا الاحراق
العشرات من المنازل وايضا الاكثر من مئه
مركبه فلسطينيه وبالتالي هذه الجرائم وهذا
المسلسل من الاعتداد سواء من جيش الاحتلال
الذي ايضا يشون حملات اعتقال مستمره على
مدار الساعه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ايضا
هناك اعتداءات وانتهاكات من قبل
المستوطنين والجانب الفلسطيني دائما يطالب
بتوفير هذه الحمايه للفلسطنين اتجاه هذا
هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي الواسع والكبير ضد
الفلسطينيين والذي يصاحب ايضا تصريحات من
قبل مسؤولين في الائتلاف الحكومي الذي
يراسه بنيامين نتنياهو من قبل وزراء
متطرفين والذين يدعون الى قتل الفلسطينيين
بشكل اكبر وايضا يطالبون الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
بتغيير قانونها بالتعامل مع الفلسطينيين
وايضا تحويل المساله من عمليه الدفاع الى
الهجوم لقتل الفلسطينيين وايضا فرض سياده
الاسرائيليه على جميع الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ابو شماله شكرا جزيلا لك